das kantonslabor 21 leistung bei einem
kleinen video auf jeden fall weiter
jetzt eine woche nicht da und jetzt bin
ich wieder dabei gleich bin ich auch
wieder nicht da auf jeden fall wollte
ich mich bei euch recht herzlich
bedanken sagt für nicht 10.000
abonnenten sondern sondern schon fast
11.500 oder 12.000 oder so geht auf
jeden fall richtig kasse letzter zeit
und das freut mich dass lenkfehler kommt
dann macht sie erst mal schnell ein
video ist zwar ich mit meiner richtigen
kamera
aber meine freude ist auch klar wenn man
hier sieht und ich weiß gleich nach
spanien habe ich mir wieder mache ich
mal so nicht follow me round aber ich
mache eine freiheit so ein zweites video
unterstreichen zusammen
ich hoffe dann bin ich schon im märz
bisschen schöner als hier
und ja auf jeden fall danke für diese
kassen abonnenten auf jeden fall dran
bleiben gibt es ein paar wichtige infos
was heißt richtige geht so bleibt
v
so also ich bin jetzt angekommen
nicht ganz aber fast als wäre es auf
ibiza kennt ihr vielleicht war
der hafen dezember zeigen dass diese
tour
weiß ja nicht was das sagt und da ist
das meer
da muss jetzt rechnet über mit dem
schiff und anders angekommen
auf jeden fall heute also ich bin jetzt
angekommen beziehungsweise schon länger
und ich habe gerade das video hier
zurecht geschnitten auf jeden fall sind
also die ein oder anderen stellen aus
der ton ein bisschen scheiße deswegen
die wichtigen informationen jetzt auch
mal hier ich stehe sogar das licht hier
und da auf jeden fall
ich habe mir der facebook-seite gemacht
wer richtig geil wenn ihr die leiden
könnte ich hatte so im hinterkopf dass
ich mit 10.000 abonnenten einfach mal
eine facebook seite mache die wollte
jetzt ein bisschen promoten und ja wer
richtig geil wenn ihr alle einfach
meinen die beschreibung klickt und dann
auf den link und an verpasst die
experten ihr einfach schnell gefällt mir
da last und ja wir auf jeden fall
richtig geil
ansonsten noch falls ihr bock auf falls
ihr bock habt dass ich hier im urlaub
einem follow me round mache oder so wenn
ich da zurzeit dann gebt dem video doch
einfach mal daumen nach oben wird mich
auf jeden fall freuen wenn ihr das
machen haben wollt ich bin müde aber ich
so viel scheiße und verspreche mich
andauernd und auf jeden fall sonst wär's
jetzt eigentlich schon gewesen wir sehen
uns dann demnächst wieder ich bin
gespannt was ihr so gesehen volt und ja
dann würde ich mal sagen haut rein mein
arm vergleich ab und sich so scheiße aus